Hi, everyone.
So, I am wondering how to start this talk
off, and I was advised that it's always best
to start off from a place of truth, so, in
that spirit of honesty, I guess I will start
off with my truth.
That is that, sometimes, well, to be honest,
a lot of times, when it comes to the web,
I actually have no idea what it is that we
are doing.
I have no idea it is we think we're doing.
Those moments of confusion tend to hit me
both as a designer and a user alike before
as a user, I find myself often confronted
with in wide array of products, most of which
are practically interchangeable, and neither
of them really make much difference to the
core task I've been trying to do with them.
And often, even when I do subscribe to any
of these products, any of these services,
I find myself quite literally afflicted by
upgrades, and changes that are poorly communicated,
and, quite frankly, don't seem to have any
real benefit to myself, and are definitely
an example of feature-creep.
Which concerns me as a designer, because,
certainly, on the local level, there's obviously
the impact on the users' direct experience,
when we think about loading times — and
I'm also particularly concerned that these
plethora of services often aren't much more
usable than the other.
They're certainly not particularly accessible,
especially when you consider, in the context
of the EU, we have about 26 per cent of EU
citizens who self-report that they live with
some form of disability, and, certainly, these
products aren't any more ethical, which, again,
is a massive concern, especially when you're
considering whether that is in terms of the
amount of time and attention they demand from
the user to the security of the users' information,
even just to how they communicate what is
connected by using the service, where the
data is coming from and where the data is
going.
When you put that in terms of the global context,
you know, when you think of all these products
and services, which are taking up reams of
service space, which has a huge environmental
cost, if you think of the 70 million servers
that contribute 2 per cent to all greenhouse
emissions, not to speak of the impact of the
production life cycle of the hardware on our
environmental, biological ecosystems, as well
as the poorest of the global population, and,
so, in that spirit of fascination and confusion
— fascination because, like many of us here,
I am someone who is generally excited and
interested, and fascinated by technologies
— and I really want to take this opportunity
to slightly provoke us as a community, and
start asking ourselves firstly what are we
actually doing here?
And really to get into how are we doing it?
So, yes, I'm sorry, but it's that time of
the day, and what we're going to talk about
is design.
A bit of content warning: the next slide has
some geometric black and white animations,
but hopefully, I won't linger on that too
long.
So, design.
What is design?
For me in the context of this talk, I'm fundamentally
talking about problem-solving.
When I talk about design and implicitly designers,
I'm talking about those of us who are creating
something with an intent, so I'm not speaking
to those of us who are backend engineers as
I am for those who are API developers and
user interface designers.
To quote, "If you're someone who moves things
from an existing condition to a preferred
one, you are a designer."
And so, if to design is to provoke movement,
questions arise such as where are we moving
to?
What are we moving from?
And perhaps, more importantly, what is it
that we are actually moving?
If we look at this ecosystem, if we think
about the things we're trying to move, one
of the most obvious things is people.
We're trying to move modes of behaviour, ways
of understanding.
These are all conditions that we may well
either be asked by our product owners, by
ideators or innovators to change, or they
may well be, that we ourselves wish to move.
Often, when we start to understand where people
are in order to understand how we could potentially
shift their behaviours and their ways of thinking,
we tend to map out their experiences in this
particular way.
We tend to this about what they think and
what they feel, what they say, and what they
hear, what they say, and what he they to.
By doing so, we are trying to get a sense
of the complexity of the person who will be
using our services and our technology.
And I say "complexity", and there is, in fact,
a clue in the way I phrase the segments of
the map, because, often in reality, what we
find, is that this is riddled with paradoxes.
There are paradoxes between the way people
think and how they feel, between what they
say and what they actually do.
Between the things they think they see or
observe, and the things that they actually
act on and take note of.
So here we have one way of trying to understand
the humans that we as designers are trying
to influence.
But already, there's a major pitfall that
we are all susceptible to, and I suspect,
given that there are fascinatingly confusing
state of things, we all too frequently give
into.
Ultimately, what happens, is that we tend
to limit the way we are mapping our users
the way we imagine and understand our users.
Too much in terms of the problem that we think
we're trying to solve.
Ultimately, what that means is that we are
inadequately framing the person who we think
we are trying to serve, and ultimately, this
is the source of the problem.
Inadequate framing of the person leads to
an inaccurate framing of the problem.
Ultimately, understanding people is meant
to help us frames problems better to generate
better outcomes.
To quote:
"It's easy to make bad choices when there
aren't many choices to begin with," and that
is impacted by our inadequate framing of the
person.
Because, ultimately, if the problem we think
we are trying to solve is all there is to
life, the universe, and everything, well,
hang on, no, because it isn't.
Ultimately, it if our job is to move things
into a preferred condition, it's vital to
understand the current condition, because
humans don't just exist in relation to the
problems that we think we are trying to solve.
In fact, as humans, we exist in relation to
many other interfering mental and social models.
We exist in relation to many other environments,
natural, social, and built.
One of those built objects, one of those built
environments, is the other object that we
are trying to move over to a preferred condition,
and that other object is the web.
Now, at its most basic, the web is created
by a computational devices communicating with
each other by an agreed protocol.
But I'm often being quite curious, because
if you think about the map we use to try to
interrogate the experience of the human, what
happens if we try to use that same map to
understand the experience of the web?
Often, what happens is that, in many ways,
we see that the same paradoxes apply.
Formula the internet is created of communications
between computers, sending bits of information
between each other, yet, this information,
regardless of the fact that it is broken down
into its binary components, is nonetheless
combined with the physical structure of the
network, the physical structure that actually
arises out of already existing evolving geopolitical
and economic infrastructures.
It's that which contributes to fundamental
inequalities, as to which languages with more
dominant, who has access to the web in the
first place, when they do, and how.
So, to clarify, what is going on is that the
inequalities we see on the web scheme from
the material nature of the web.
These inequalities that impact what people
get to read, see, how secure their data might
be, and indeed how safe they might be as a
citizen of their country.
And it's the materiality of the web which
is where, as designers, our concern for the
environmental impact of the web should also
come in.
After all, all those servers are what helps
to contribute to the fact that the web is
the fourth largest producer of C02 after the
United States, China, and India.
What you have is an object made up of the
relationship between the human and the web,
or our solution, the things that transmits
movement to the system to move this relationship
to a different way of being, actually becomes
a part of the system.
Ultimately, the intersection of the web, the
user, and whatever additional dynamics we
create will create in turn another emergent
system, and, like all emergent systems, it
is complex in nature.
It is chaotic, and unpredictable, arises into
huge and often un seen phase shifts.
Sometimes, it's often what results in cases
like this.
So this is a screen shot from a developer,
Jackie Arsino, who is one of who noticed that
the fact that the facial recognition software
that Google had put in place was incapable
of realising that black people were, in fact,
human beings, and, instead, categorised them
as gorillas.
I always point to this example, partly because
it is pretty famous, and most people have
at least heard an inkling of it, but I think
in terms of what I'm trying to talk about,
in terms of designing for this human and web
system, it highlights some of the key assumptions
that we tend to infect our solutions with.
It highlights assumptions about what aspects
of the human need to be taken into consideration,
and particularly in the case of this example,
my lights our assumptions about our ability
to manage and solve any resultant errors in
the service we think we are providing.
Seeing this kind of stuff is fascinating for
me as a user-experience designer, because
it is enough to make anyone cry.
Do you even design!
A lot of what is happening is that we are
too busy framing our design research into
how it directly applies to the problem we
want to solve.
We're ignoring the noise because it doesn't
seem to be relevant.
If this is something I myself am totally susceptible
to.
I'm from the UK, a society that is still massively
riven by class and racial inequalities, and
even I sometimes will fall prey to this.
I have to remember that myself, as a middle
class cis-gendered university educated abled
citizen of a first-world Anglophone nation,
that so much of what I might perceive as just
additional and extra bits of information essentially,
the noise in my research data, is not, in
fact, noise.
Who is going on is simply my relative privilege
impeding my ability to interpret the data.
It's not noise.
It's just your privilege talking.
The designed object, after all, is a revelatory
object.
It reveals our assumptions about people, our
assumptions about how we think the world works,
or, indeed, how we think it doesn't.
It certainly isn't neutral, and, as a child
of humanity, technology can never be neutral.
So, when we are designing things that will
be used by people, we need to check how we
think about people, and how we think about
the world.
We all, after all, have multiple facets to
ourselves as to how we are seen by society.
The work of Kimblely Crenshaw, who invented
the word "intersectionality", with , that
work came out of rigorous analysis about how
legislation in the United States at the time
couldn't fully account for the discriminatory
experience faced by black women in the workplace.
As people who were both black and women, the
legal system couldn't adequately frame their
experience being a combination of sexism and
racism.
And so, similarly, like that legal system,
our technologies may not be able to adequately
frame the experiences of our users and could,
as a result, put them at risk from the inequality
that they already interface with in their
society, and, in fact, that our technologies
will in turn interface and being be impacted
by.
It's not noise.
It's just your privilege talking.
So, I promised that this would also have something
a bit practical.
I guess now, the most obvious question is:
well, hey, you, teaching us how to design,
what can we try instead?
What I always like to say is first off start
by reaching out and opening up.
Reach out.
Get your technology looked at.
Get your technology considered from a different
perspective.
If you're living in a university city, or
nearby a research institute, find out who
your local digital humanities academics are.
Get in touch with ethnographers and social
historians who will have experience in analysing
hundreds of years worth of data concerning
human behaviour and the interaction with technology.
If your city has an impact hub, or a maker
space, reach out to them, and get them involved
in critiquing, with ideating and testing the
solutions and your technology that might help
them.
Working in machine-learning?
Join the Algorithmic Justice League to raise
concerns that you might have about how well
the data set has been formulated.
If you're already in development phase or
thinking about pushing upgrades, use gamified
interventions like the Tarot Card of Tech
to help you design and improve architecture
flexible enough to handle the various situations
that even a single persona can find themselves
in.
Even if it is almost too late to which those
changes to your ways of working, at the very
least, it help you be honest about where the
potential security and social risks for users
will be.
The next tip is to design your technology
as a service.
What a does that mean?
What it means, to paraphrase the service design
network, is that think about how you're designing
the infrastructure, the communication between
the different levels of your systems, and
the material components of the service will
interact not just with the people who are
using the service, but also with the service
provider.
Your solution is in 19 ways a go-between between
two already existing complex systems.
Design the whole life cycle; design what happens
if it breaks or degrades; design how people
will deal with it if they have issues with
it, what happens if the user dies.
What happens to their data then?
Design, design.
Think about this.
The other thing that might also be helpful
as a fun little exercise: actually map out
the experience of your solution as though
it were a person — and I'm honestly not
trying to be cute.
Actually pin down how is it that your solution
thinks?
How does it feel?
What does it think about its users?
What is the mental model of your technology?
What can it understand about people?
Are they just first and last name?
Do they usual social media.
Do they see what other things the user transmits
across the vast ecosystem of the web?
What does your technology see and hear from
other services and other technologies?
Most importantly, I would advise you to remember,
and to understand the person, the human being,
as multi-dimensional, and, remember that complexity
in any complex system comes from the most
basic component: the variations that exist
within that system are often what lead to
wide divergences in behaviours and phases.
And then, for us, as designers of the web,
that complexity comes from the human.
So, think.
How their context informs even their non-task
related needs.
Is it always safe for them to use social media
logins to gain access to your service.
If they have done, can they, and are they
empowered to change what information is displayed?
One of the things that always frankly annoys
me quite significantly is if I'm using — logging
into a solution, and I can, for example, use
my Twitter handle to log in — and yet I
can't change the image.
I can't change it into, say, a generic avatar
in case I don't want people to realise it
is the same person on Twitter and meet-up
or wherever else using this particular product.
So, what other issues?
How do they report if something goes wrong
with the solution, either in terms of the
other users they're encountering, or with
the solution itself in can you build this
at scale?
Always consider how your solution will be
used in the context of the other.
Someone as different from you as possible.
Consider how your tech might be used by, or
impact someone, who was homeless, someone
who was a refugee, someone who is a woman,
someone who is trans, someone with varying
power supply in their local context.
If it seems tokenistic, well, to be honest,
that says more about your technology than
the design process.
If considering the multiplicity of human experience
comes across as tokenistic, quite, frankly,
that's because your technology is already
objectifying people, so check yourself: do
people actually need the service that you
think you're providing?
If you're truly convinced that people do,
then I'm afraid you need to be ready to get
uncomfortable and start engaging with the
realities of human existence.
A really great way, then, to account for this
complexity is what often gets called design-jamming,
and, you know, the famous saying how it goes:
if you can't beat 'em, involve 'em.
Even before acceptance testing, get co-creating
with your users, testers, and auditors.
What you will end up with are technologies
that are much more resilient and have a more
durable end-to-end service, because, instead
of having to react to the complexity once
they're out there in the ecosystem, they have
already have imbibed that complexity as part
of the basic architecture of the product.
If you need help — and you may well do,
and that's fine — there's a huge service
design network out there filled with friendly
and excited designers who are itching to help
you design the technologies of the future
which is be human-centred, ethical, and accessible.
By 2020, it's estimated there will be 200
billion connected devices, changing zeta bytes'
worth of data.
Yet, if the foundational technologies that
allow us to analyse and extract a value from
this data to create our products, if those
foundation al technologies are built in hope
rather than on the evidence about our intersectional
realities, that means we create an ever greater
pile-up of digital gunk that no-one really
needs, increases our environmental deficit,
and puts us all at increased risk from cyber
and socio-political attacks.
I implore you, therefore, as a fellow designer.
Think broader than your problem.
Think broader than your screens.
Think broader than your personas.
Think broader than your neat little plugins.
Think broader.
Make inclusively, and start designing better.
Thank you.
[Cheering and Applause]